bom dia a todos é como o jovem nilson
nelson mas hoje o meu nome não é apenas
o shamo fátima céu rita suzana nelson
porque estou aqui a representar a equipe
do centro de desenvolvimento e dinamiza
as atividades do curso maxx
o que mata é o clube matemática da
faculdade de ciência e tecnologia daniel
estamos sediado no departamento de
matemática e organizando em sete sessões
durante a noite soluções que duram desde
às 3 da tarde até às 8 horas e estão
dirigidas para alunos do ensino básico e
secundário era perceberem o que nós
fazemos para o cade no tempo até 2007
quando o prêmio de matemática e resolveu
trazer aqui a faculdade a exposição jogo
assim 13 jogos país preparada pela
organização é trata é uma exposição
cheia de equipamentos e materiais e
pequenos objetos manipulados que os
visitantes podem manipular nem cheira e
utilizar para realizar uma diversas as
presenças confirmadas com concentre as
vendas durante o mês de ver nas escolas
é que nos visitavam 34 escolas durante o
dia e escrita dizer que estar sempre
presentes 23 do centro do programa de
matemática tomar em conta da destruição
não só explicar aos visitantes como é
que as brigas eram realizadas 24 foi
garantido no final da exposição todo
aquele equipamento subiria estava em
gostar tanto de governos e que um dia em
que criou o fat 6 céu estávamos alguma
coisa da exposição e começamos a
comentários com os outros e paramos no
tempo final não é que quando colhia uma
turma do 2º ciclo 1º ciclo é era uma
tarde muito barulhenta com os 1.000
discutido cismados a fazer um chifrinho
querer mexer em tudo e experimentar tudo
era cansativo mas divertido quando
recebemos uma turma dos com dário o e do
final do que sei se tu é coisa era mais
incisivo
e há até um telemóvel um novo ea
colaborar cinema locatário ou seja
aquela magia é que um breve momento
ídolo de aprenderem novas coisas e
experimentar novas experiências
tinha de ter sido tantas crianças não
odiava matemática mas algures ao longo
do percurso de aula assim também entrou
lado o flu que foi fico tem explica
energia e portanto queremos que isso
acontecerá porque não acontecerá e claro
estavam desconfiados que é o hormônio
tenham cada vez que o assunto em
anunciantes e outros interesses à
vontade de entregar os pais e tal mas
como nós tínhamos filhos em idade
escolar mas que eram os universitários
não tínhamos contato com grupos de
estudantes daquela idade então ficamos
com uma curiosidade e assim a 2 de junho
de 2007 tivemos a sessão é inaugural do
combate
é nessa altura apenas menos três
campeões os iniciados dedicados aos
alunos do segundo ciclo o juiz para os
alunos dos 6 5 finalmente os juniores
para os alunos do secundário com um
problema bom baixo de que estou livre a
fé e até causou alguma celeuma quando
perceber qualquer lema
depois por medir a resistência dos pais
que vinham das nossas funções são as
aves não é intenção dos pais são
responsáveis por fazer os nossos
associados ações e vingou ea e tatá que
o meu filho que está no sexto ano e tal
mas quem é que está no santos a quem não
pôde assistir e nós vimos a não é
humilde não têm maturidade para fazer
atividades o preparador pessoal do
segundo 57 anos atearam e aos 34 anos
atrás
resolvemos alargar o combate ao primeiro
ciclo e convidados
rita e é susana posou também a equipa e
assim surgiram mais dois quilombos
ministro para mim do 1º e 2º ano e os
infantis para - do 3º e 4º anos
maturidade também são diferentes
nesta altura nós temos cerca de 100
associados é e posso dizer vos que a
volta de 50 por cento mais ou menos
limitada são humildes do primeiro ciclo
neste momento o foco do formato mais
concentrado nos
esse quadro mais baixos dos mais o vácuo
é nós organizamos durante as nossas
funções atividades lúdicas matemática
sempre é feita às formas dos nossos
associados possam experimentar
constantemente matrix mesma forma
divertida tanto a idéia é ea luz sem se
perceber estão acharam uma temática
muito gira que é uma coisa bastante
divertida
não é que elas é que nos tentam vender e
não pelo prazer fui experimentar
matemática em teoria a realidade 300 nós
continuamos sem conseguir namorar muitos
os anunciantes
tanto os canal dedicado aos alunos do
secundário tem 23 associados que nós
andamos em enfim é um dos meus
envolvemos com os outros mais novos nos
abandonamos
mas lidar com 205 é sempre complicado
a verdade é que fazemos vai ao longo
destes oito anos também já extinta em
preparamos um total de 56 sessões e
dividir por mais vários cães detalhes
são muitas atividades que não vou
conseguir instaladas todas representadas
apenas algumas pra ter idéia do que
fazer depois podem visitar o nosso site
e o tempo lá todas as outras atividades
já na casa de não falte tínhamos trilhos
de pegadas espalhadas aprofundados
miltinho nos encontrar com o deslinde
medir as pegadas grande distância entre
as pegadas e com ela usando modelos
matemáticos tripulavam tentavam estimar
a altura da perna do bicho ea velocidade
que eu iria aproveitarmos a exposição
matéria para fazer uma viagem pelo
sistema solar
fizemos - não só lá andamos à procura do
mercúrio e dos verbos e de terra e por
aí fora e depois tentarmos calcular como
é que nós conseguimos construir um
modelo como está a escola e andamos lá
por uns 1000 deportados a fazer umas
contas com os números muito grandes e os
que eram todos contentes que trabalharam
com milhares de milhões e milhões e e
acrescenta é provavelmente alguns de
vocês a normativa que há sentimento
entanto viram eu só vou gostar e os dois
devem se lembrar dos cabelos continham
as nossas miniaturas dos planetas
já tivemos uma sessão lupi
as sessões dedicadas à arte andamos a
trabalhar com frisos e padrões já
tivemos uma sessão dedicada somente
platônico montante só usa parte
panificações usamos balões usados pelas
linhas para criar o solo e tônicos já
temos uma noção de cada magia cerro já
fizemos truques na tecnologia
já tivemos uma sessão dedicada à música
onde pegamos uma pauta aplicamos as
loterias e vivo que conhecia a que
aludia quanto cada após a aplicação das
opressões isométricas já tivemos
situações onde criava os nossos
tubulares jogos chegou a humilde nos
pneus e óleo toma falar esta fita temos
aqui pergunta de um trio temos aqui por
muito tempo faz lá pagando a seca eu
quiser fazer isso em casa fazer o tps
não obrigado
'nesse criar um tablado jogos do jogo
uma mecânica qualquer divertida e
inventaram que vocês esta casa tem que
responder uma pergunta de um teria eu
respondi que não tá fazendo tpc está
detido
já um dia fomos melhor mãos e fizemos um
mega super grande labirinto que ocupava
o chão todo o edifício seta todo também
não as salas de aulas mas os curadores
dos atores todos os vários episódios
pinto labirinto e os mandaram a
percorrer o labirinto
já fizemos o gol temos uma sessão
dedicada xadrez humano quando os mil
disseram as peças e tenho que resolver
uma situação é uma situação de pobreza
ou seja é ao longo desses oito anos
inúmeras inúmeros atirados e organizamos
sempre na altura mais ou menos da parte
com uma caixa automática e no final do
ano letivo em junho é uma casa um peddy
paper um trilho matemático 2009 por
correrem o caps é claro só consegui
fazer isso tudo graças também à ajuda do
pagamento da temática dos nossos colegas
que se manteriam para nos apoiar nessa
retirada a tempo de tomar conta dos
humildes e manter o nível de entusiasmo
deus controlável e também ajuda os
nossos países é impossível mesmo alguns
colegas do departamento e caso não sejam
em visitas e preparam atividades para os
nossos míldio e os nossos alunos da
faculdade que não teriam como monitores
em que já tudo daqui umas caras de
a divisão muito aluno soldado foram
nossos associados também aqui o jogo ao
invadir o palco também foi nós é
essencial do formato é neste momento
tanto mato está muito concentrado nos
níveis de educação mais baixos níveis do
primeiro ciclo essencialmente e mais
nova está no extremo no extremo oposto
da nova escola joão dedicava dirigida a
alunos do ensino secundário
eu fiquei um pouco constrangido estar
aqui falar da mais nova porque eu tenho
conseguido se esquivar uma forma
descarada a todos os convites que fazer
parte da comissão organizadora das mais
novas
assumo tem que ser um monte de coisa por
fazer e acaba sempre nunca está sentindo
a edição deste ano mas é muito
interessante e estou falando eu portanto
a céu como fátima já organizaram mais
novas e na realidade oceania rita já
tivemos envolvidos em atividades da
marca nova portanto faz sentido de
evitarem falar da nova é uma escola de
verão ocorrem em setembro e é dirigido
especificamente paulo de que concluíram
o 11º ano e meio depois terão começado a
subir assim segundo ele é uma forma
descarada de namorar aqui ostensivas
candidatos alguns aqui na faculdade e é
uma forma de obter em contato com
matemática nível ensino superior é é
ainda sem serem alunos do ensino
superior a adotarem estando a terminar o
seu o seu ensino secundário é que ela é
página da mais nova da edição 2001 já
existe desde 2010 2011
o jogo durante uma nova os participantes
têm um custo que escolhe a tentar uma
panóplia por seus muitos escrevem dizem
qual é o custo que nem se tiro e
assistem palestras do seminário e no fim
tem de preparar uma apresentação para
mostrar aos colegas que assistiram ao
discurso que aprenderam durante essa
semana
além disso eles tenham a possibilidade
de viver com os nossos alunos com os
alunos dos núcleos e também um seguindo
o que acontece na universidade e por
acontecer me dão lhe é um um ano letivo
ora estas nossas experiências pouco
matiko mais nova fizeram com que nós
tivéssemos abertos é formas diferentes
de passar o conhecimento matemática e
é no ano passado fomos desafiados a
integrar a equipe que concorreu é um
projecto europeu
o projeto me mate 15 mi kim é o projeto
ponto de partida foi dado por uma colega
nossa então de ana e manuela luddy que
pertence à universidade pelo dia e
portanto ela contatou quatro equipas
vários países europeus espera que
desaparece ganhamos o projeto tem estado
a implementar a equipe inglesa pertença
à universidade chef laura a equipa
húngara pretensa é algo que não tem ação
para dizer que é o que quer dizer a uma
universidade no meu mundo é horrível e é
o que está situado em budapeste é e que
promeve apresentou matemático que é um
museu exclusivamente dedicada à
matemática situado enguiço e nós os 5
somos a equipa portuguesa a
representação da universidade nova de
lisboa
este é o site do projeto nosso objetivo
é muito simples que mostrar no terreno
uma coisa que já sabe é que as crianças
com idades entre os oito e dez anos
seguem quarto ano no sistema nem sempre
conseguem apreender com o santos o
extrato she is pensarmos paulo as mãos
actividade de massas têm seus nomes
serem objecto manipulável conseguem
compreender os conceitos
depois é só dar o salto para passar em
pó abstrato como é que funcionários
nossos cada país a equipe propôs duas
atividades mãos na massa que permite
estas crianças dependem um conceito
matemático
fizemos uma só pessoa nós temos em
portugal se pudesse escola trabalhar
conosco é deus possui escolheram as
atividades que vão fazer com os mil dias
19 e 21 de maio foram os exames do 4º
ano de tantas pessoas até essa altura
estava nos atentados mas a partir dessa
altura as causas tentado realizar as
atividades com os humildes organizar
exposições e objetivos mildred exposição
o estranho aos seus pais aos seus pares
ea primeira vez será o que aprenderam
matemática durante durante o do projeto
já agora se quiserem conhecer coisas
caras dos nossos colegas é europeus
podem visitar o site e também estão mais
admirados todas com pequenos vídeos
quiserem podia vai cuidar do vazamento
que a queda da atividade fácil esta e
até a página do projeto no facebook
tomou estradas
esperava o ônibus para visitar a página
no facebook faça um laico
a comissão do pac missão européia o
número do lápis na página do facebook é
muito importante
no entanto vão lá e também para me ver
as fotografias de coisas nós temos
andado a fazer barulho da lancheria nas
atividades que nós propusemos e que tem
estado a ser implementadas nas escolas é
essa é a nossa proposta portuguesa tinha
que falar nelas portanto são coisas que
nós experimentamos no combate obviamente
a construção de frisos e modulação é
tanto a questão do modelo à escala do
nosso sistema solar
outras duas propostas não é construção
de pavimentações totalizando triângulo
equilátero os coloridos explicar porquê
que o funcionário tem que o fazer aquela
pavimentação epidemia dos corpos que
fizeram o triângulo que o funciona é
sempre a exploração do incor aero
nostrum carlos alberto todos ficamos com
as pirâmides e este é bastante singular
tribunal e uma bola de futebol e com
isso compramos os rapazes todos que
participaram no projecto das várias
panificações do cubo utilizando um
leãozinho e duas pulgas virtuais um
crime e que expôs ao candidato e sim
vertis apenas através dos dizer estas
propriedades do dote quebre com bico que
na realidade é o sólido que as abelhas
usam para construir os favos de mel que
levou misture formam um conjunto
compacto é muito estável e é possível
assinar também com o clube com as
pirâmides em conceitos mundo é o
conceito bastante abstrato
são atividades sempre nos na massa todas
elas produzem manipuláveis e todas elas
permitem às crianças de conseguir
atingir constantes do estado precisando
pelo pelo concreto são é muito muito
versáteis nós descobrimos a posteriori
que é muito fácil torná los mais
complexas
estendemos alguns mais velhos e muito
cincos torná las mais é acessíveis a um
dos mais novos inclusivamente uma das
escolas onde é introduzida tácito estava
é tanto uma turma é apenas uma chamada
apenas por alunos com necessidades
educativas especiais entanto foi super
compensando a nossa colega e amiga
aplicou no treino
ver mesmo é que os alunos conseguem diz
crianças de filme match conseguir
entender ao atender alguns conceitos
finalmente tem todas as caldas nesta
altura o realizaram estão a realizar as
suas posições e nós em setembro teremos
alguém na nossa biblioteca uma exposição
final um dos melhores conteúdos das
escolas viram precário e e vocês poderão
visitar ano e as mas não deixa de se
manter o esperado em termos tão atentos
e visitamos o país tem que fazer o
relatório da exposição eo número de
visitantes é um indicador faz ser
observado pela comissão que vai avaliar
o sucesso do do projeto e para terminar
eu só posso dizer que estas aventuras
todas agora vou falar em em no meu nome
portanto não em nome da equipe visando o
meu nome é obviamente cada um de nós
meta nossa postura nas nossas atividades
do com mato e ilumina e de mais nova mas
na realidade o que também acontece o
contrário
o fato de termos que conviver com esse
time determinado também molda um pouco a
maneira nós temos uma sala de aulas e
obviamente quando o piso uma sala de
aulas
já não faço como fazia oito anos há nove
anos atrás portanto a minha maneira de
estar perante a audiência mudou e por
não ter essa unidade curricular que o s
ona e eu sei que consiga evitar o lino e
fiz qualquer mais - não vai ter qualquer
idade de volta e apresentar uma forma
mais divertida principal antigos se eu
conseguir manter os alunos interessados
tenham circus conseguinte os nossos em
teus conseguirem aprender alguma coisa e
protestos que mostrar muito obrigado por
você quiser